un llamado a la huelga este 19 de enero
por la propuesta del aumento de la edad
de jubilación en Francia la movilización
será sin duda muy fuerte en el sector
público no estamos viendo una fuerte
movilización en las empresas privadas en
este momento pero de nuevo soy muy cauto
porque la experiencia demuestra que
nadie Realmente capaz de predecir cómo
evolucionará un movimiento social en
nuestro país la idea del gobierno de
macron es aumentar en dos años la edad
para jubilarse y aprobarse la iniciativa
de los franceses podrán acceder a este
derecho a los 64 años y no a los 62 como
está estipulado actualmente es decir a
partir de 2027 habrá que haber trabajado
43 años para cobrar una pensión completa
el descontento causado por el proyecto
hará que los servicios de trenes metros
aviones centrales eléctricas y radio
televisión pública paren para roba un
fontanero que ha trabajado durante 40
años bajo las casas de los franceses la
nueva medida le parece contraproducente
empiezas cuando mujeres muy jóvenes si
eres aprendiz empiezas a los 16 si vas a
una escuela profesional son los 18 pero
verás entre los 18 y los 60 años ya
llevas 42 años arrastrándote por el
suelo y por eso cuando te dicen que
tienes que trabajar dos años más eso
parece mucho tiempo no es solo como un
paseo de 2 años por el parque
en las calles la gente quiere que haga
debate con respecto al proyecto
puedo entender que la gente necesita
explicaciones que no esté contenta lo
entiendo Me gustaría que hubiera más
debate sobre esto que se negociara un
poco más en vez de así brutalmente
poniendo a la gente en un aprieto sin
explicaciones o con explicaciones que
parecen un poco falsas
el gobierno señala que la reforma es
necesaria para equilibrar las cuentas
explicación que no comparten los
sindicatos quienes podrían llamar a
extender la huelga